hey what's going on a spill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday January 18 2016 how does it go in
a lie I am recording this Sunday
afternoon and in Vancouver Canada doing
two shows here tonight it's halftime
actually third quarter just started of
the Bronco Steelers I missed Seattle in
Carolina I know that must have been a
great [ __ ] game it kills me you know
you never know when you book the [ __ ]
gig so a game like that it's going to be
on but I imagine that that was as good
as the score look and of course I'm up
here in Canada and I don't know they
don't have they just went to boomer and
all those guys at halftime and all he
did was interview Cam Newton they asked
him one question you know and he didn't
answer you know he just talked didn't
give an answer about anything he did in
the second half Taylor a long blunt he
just goes well your offensive our
defense and of course the special teams
you know everybody's got a job to do and
they get out there and they try to get
done and unfortunately today we were
able to get out there and execute some
of the things would be working with all
this week and oh you know next week we
got another person that we're going to
be playing I should set a team not a
person being on team we're going to play
and we just hope that you know we're
just gonna try to keep it going because
you know we're trying to win a
championship here and by then you decide
what the [ __ ] that I even asked you
I wonder if you know cuz athletes
anything they [ __ ] say they're going
to take it out of context so they just
they get trained to just answer or not
say anything just like a politician I
wanted you can [ __ ] turn that off you
know if you stay in the league long
enough if you drive your wife nuts you
know honey you know where my shows are
well you know you want to love stuff and
sometimes that stuff gets misplaced that
all you can do is just try to fire on
all cylinders and try to find the things
that you can have and now if you can
find them you can find them and if you
can't then you got to move on to the
next thing but uh you know as always I'm
always looking towards next week and
another thing that's going to be lost in
us plus well we're definitely going to
do everything we can to find it kinda
the offense defense and special teams
you're not happy anyways yes I'm up here
in Vancouver god damn it it's [ __ ]
beautiful up here [ __ ] gorgeous man
especially when you live in you know
where the hell I live which was not
designed to have really anybody living
there other than I guess maybe some
indigenous people sending smoke signals
you know probably sending smoke signals
that you know can you find any food
because we can't I'm sick of eating
snake and do you want to get the [ __ ]
out of here however the [ __ ] you do that
with smoke signals it must've been
pretty goddamn simple right the smoke
signal if they even did it or is that
just another Hollywood thing that they
threw a blonde I mean how do you even
[ __ ] do that I guess you had to go
obviously you got to put the fire out
right why would it go ahead how the [ __ ]
would you do that you know alright one
big pops of [ __ ] D I don't know what
kind of wood to burn what a pain in the
ass Jesus Christ let me get lost and
then we're getting lost at the mall
before a [ __ ] cell phone that was
unbelievable forget about back then if
you get lost it when you will [ __ ]
anybody see what the [ __ ] was that guy's
name Oh [ __ ] red face where'd he go
done I mean how long do you look you
can't really yell you're going to
attract wild animals just walking around
the woods
hey Eddie Eddie [ __ ] are you this is
funny man anyways but you come up here
after leaving the desert whenever I see
you say the desert I always think of
that often that great greg Giraldo rest
to soul joke where he just did that
whole thing about how eloquent the words
the words the notes were that soldiers
wrote during the Civil War you know
versus some of the letters from people
coming back from Iraq
when I came in about [ __ ] one it's
really hard to be out here with the ball
sticking to your leg out here in the
desert you know I remember the
differencing desert and desert two S's
for desert more calories right there you
go that's how I do it
don't even ask me to spell restaurant
because I won't even [ __ ] remember so
anyways I'm up here in Vancouver which
we go to [ __ ] land and just oh my god
all the lush greenery all the lakes
although what everything we don't have
down in LA beautiful houses I guess
expensive [ __ ] up here and they were
saying how a lot of Asian people you
know not indigenous to foreigners you
know they got to get rid of their
[ __ ] money got to wash their money or
I don't want the [ __ ] is their
governments going to take it all so they
use this place up here like a Swiss bank
and they buy like super expensive places
for cash which drives the housing market
up it's [ __ ] nuts man anytime you go
to another country just hear the [ __ ]
that they're [ __ ] dealing with I did
you know you always think like you come
up here Canada is going to have no
[ __ ] problems you know you watch one
Michael Moore documentary that just
gives you a complete like
misinterpretation of what the [ __ ] is
going on up here so they I guess they
had to make some sort of law that you
couldn't do something like that I can't
I came out this [ __ ] person told him
one always while the waiter the [ __ ]
Supreme Court there was like a group of
people from Asia that was so rich that
they actually sued an entire country for
not letting them either come into the
country or buy a bunch of [ __ ] over here
that drove the housing market stuff up
or something like that or buy their
citizenship I can't even [ __ ]
remember but that's the charm and it's
podcast you know I get a little
information I barely remember half of it
I just [ __ ] run with it that's all so
anyways so it went all the way to the
Supreme Court and they were just finally
like yeah you kinda have to be from this
country for us to give a [ __ ] about you
you know to like win a lawsuit so see
you later
that's intended I get the lawyer for
them new the whole way going all the way
up that it wasn't going to happen you
know they weren't going to win it he
just took their money he probably had to
sit there and work on his uh I'm
disappointed we lost to face you know as
he took all this [ __ ] money
but anyways so let's talk about NFL
football what Papa Papa do get it get it
in the [ __ ] Patriots they won goddamn
it thank Christ they won thank Christ
they wanted Seattle lost thank Christ
you know we're going to keep advancing I
just didn't want to Seattle get the
revenge I can't remember if I've already
said this I just didn't want to see
Seattle get the revenge on a banged up
Patriot team we come in healthy and they
kick our ass good on them but uh you
know congratulations to the Carolina
Panthers they got to be the favorites at
this point come on the sixteen and
[ __ ] one right got that young defense
then I'd scared of [ __ ] they just beat
Seattle right who knows but um I don't
know [ __ ] about football I've just been
so [ __ ] busy so I'm still going to
talk about it you guys can keep
thrashing me that I don't know [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] and by the way this is
why I never record on a day that I flew
because my brain is even more all over
the place than it usually is especially
when I got a [ __ ] TV going on in the
background but uh you know I got I got a
busy [ __ ] day time I fly back
tomorrow got a busy [ __ ] day so I
apologize if this is all over the place
even more than usual eyes up first out
[ __ ] twenty five I hope somebody else
up here gives a [ __ ] about NFL football
I know they have CFL ends I'm like if at
the end of November they have the Grey
Cup which is their Super Bowl or is it a
December I don't know the people even
give a [ __ ] you ever see the [ __ ]
stadiums for their football teams up
here it's like you sit in the stands you
can see a car you know one of those
deals where there's like a [ __ ] you
watch them kick a field goal and you're
looking at traffic driving by on the
street that's like those old school
football stadiums from like the 60s and
70s you
where they would have liked the
horseshoe-shaped stadium which was I
think what happened with what the
football stadiums was when there wasn't
that many people in the or and also the
league's were small they just had people
sitting on both sides right he had the
home side in the visitor side and that
was it and then as there's more and more
people population got bigger the
league's got bigger then they built
endzone seats that connected both sides
I think they just did it on one side
first then he had the horseshoe right
like the [ __ ] Broncos played in the
Buckeyes the Buckeye still called their
horse they still call it a horseshoe
even though they [ __ ] closed in it
and then eventually there was people
people did so much [ __ ] that they had
to close you know and there's so much
ESPN that got everybody [ __ ]
interested in it that isn't even
interested in it then all of a sudden
beyond facing and it [ __ ] halftime
you know and there's a bunch of people
in the crowd that are excited by ya
[ __ ] old-ass Rod Stewart who the [ __ ]
they draggin out there you always you to
go with somebody younger they just
[ __ ] drag somebody who out who's on
their last [ __ ] legs
like that last big payday you know they
just [ __ ] wheel them out there cuz
I'm gonna do this year Night Ranger it's
either going to be like Night Ranger a
Drake that's what I'm guessing oh wait I
think it is Beyonce you know I know cuz
Nia wanted to go the Superbowl because
Beyonce was there I'm like when are you
going to see your in concert you're
going to make us go to the [ __ ] Super
Bowl and then we're going to watch your
lip-sync one [ __ ] song how to [ __ ]
that Sean Penn interview that drug lord
how do you do something like that and
the government isn't like hey you know
we're trying to find that guy you know
you're sitting had Palin around with
them probably bought them like Fast
Times at Ridgemont High DVDs right for
his underground lair
dude I love Sean Penn is an actor but
how do you [ __ ] tree are you that
you're going to go and interview that
[ __ ] guy you know I did that I'm
trying to think how many [ __ ]
stand-up specials I would have to put
out before I could go I would go [ __ ]
interview somebody in like I'd be well I
guess Isis is actually fight but we're
[ __ ] with them too you know I would
just think I'm gonna walk in me with my
microphone they're all going to laugh at
me and then they're going to saw my
[ __ ] head off or even worse tie me to
a chair [ __ ] torture me to death that
can say hey good on him also I don't
know if that El Chapo that's his name he
sounds like such a gentleman huh LJ's a
good chap El Chapo I don't [ __ ] get
it man what are you doing why did he go
down there and interview that guy and
like how how well does Sean Penn's
movies do that drug dealers on the run
he's on the run from our government
right isn't the guy who escaped I don't
[ __ ] know you know what's going on is
my [ __ ] internet won't let me sign on
so I can't [ __ ] see anything I can't
see the [ __ ] highlights nothing you
know all I'm up here that [ __ ] got
one goddamn channel and a bunch of Tim
Hortons [ __ ] commercials which is it
Dunkin Donuts see if I can sign on here
you know el Chapo the guy that like that
we would that keeps escaping from jail
that the guy el chapo come on man come
on
ah this connection is untrusted not
Jesus Christ it's probably some psycho
from Alberta trying to hack in here that
seems like there's texas commission when
you up here so [ __ ] oil men and
ranchers and [ __ ] and then you got
admitted Simonton seems like it's nice
you don't I mean like that's their like
business hub
you know I'm totally judging these just
by doing like driving through and doing
a little bit of stand-up out here like
when I did stand-up in Calgary great
people but [ __ ] animals jesus [ __ ]
christ they were animals I don't because
the place that we performed at there was
like no carpeting or nothing
they were [ __ ] I think it was ghosts
because it was bring your own beer
[ __ ] animals I would never [ __ ] with
anybody from Calgary I saw the way they
behaved when they were in a good mood
excited for a show don't have a [ __ ]
with anybody from Calgary I went to
Edmonton was civilized Calgary Jesus
Christ they had everything but a hooker
swinging from a swing you know back in
the old days with the saloons we had the
horse you know way overdressed once
again it might just be a [ __ ] movie
thing so much so much of my history is
based on that by the way I can't get on
the [ __ ] Internet but for some reason
I can [ __ ] uh I could do it over the
I could do it on my phone let me look up
El Chapo here like I said he sounds like
such a chap I just think like that
English link and then Champa Hanna I
mean in Mexican check how Mexico
secretly launched a crackdown after Penn
met El Chapo how El Chapo was finally
captured again that was one day ago will
El Chapo rat out rival cartels corrupt
officials it's got to be a lot of stress
being this el chapo guy huh Joaquin
Guzman you know I got to say he looks
like a Mexican Robert Blake like during
the beretta years now when he says yeah
that's me who's also on the phone and it
sucks left how else this is when you
know you lived a [ __ ] crazy life this
is just the front page of this guy's for
if you search this guy's name how El
Chapo was finally captured again will El
Chapo rally I read those chapo guzman
Sean Penn talked about him El Chapo had
erectile dysfunction surgery while on
the run that's nice now he took a pit
stop you know guy takes care of himself
how nervous was that doctor working on
that maniacs dick
uh El Chapo speaks Rolling Stone Sean
Penn has terrible regret about meeting
El Chapo what did he think he was going
to meet that is going to get some
[ __ ] cherry Berry's the hunt for El
Chapo Joaquin el chapo guzman the truth
about the jailbreak there's nothing here
about a an older wiser el chapo puts out
a little singer-songwriter jesus [ __ ]
christ
do you know realize how [ __ ] finish
we are just as is a just as a race as a
race as humanity sometimes I say just as
people were [ __ ] done
you know rolling stone rolling stone
this month as Sean Penn talking to El
Chapo and Leonardo DiCaprio's on the
cover and they're billing him he has a
plan to save the planet what are we
doing what the [ __ ] is our government
not doing that a list [ __ ] actors
have to talk to drug lords and try to
save the planet I mean there's got to be
how many leaks are in the [ __ ] dam at
this point I don't know why you guys
that does not make me feel comfortable
you know I need boomer esiason to figure
out how to [ __ ] and colonize Mars that's
the next thing that they can have in the
rolling rolling stone you know what else
[ __ ] do I want to hear that can I hear a
scientist you know how about I have a
Navy SEAL interview El Chapo a Nobel how
would you shut the [ __ ] up I will I
don't know
I get unsettled I get unsettled him I'm
glad problems with digestion I can't
even remember what the [ __ ] I was going
to look up what was I initially looking
up before I got to El Chapo Jesus Christ
some of the stories on that guy you know
it's right up there with that [ __ ]
Rod Stewart rumor from way back in the
day remember that one
I think was I can even run through it
yeah they found like a gallon of jizz in
his stomach his stomach had to be pumped
you know a gallon he went to Trader
Joe's and busted him up [ __ ] all
natural organic [ __ ] I'm sorry he got a
gallon of it you know know you went to
was this what's that place do you buy
everything in bulk those [ __ ] whales
that pushing around those pallet jacks
buying Cheerios you got to get a
membership to it because with a see it's
not kunti what's the name of that I
never go to the [ __ ] place once I had
to go in there and get a membership they
wanted on this [ __ ] information oh
Christ what the [ __ ] is it called that
coat check I'm never going to remember
it you know what I'm saying that just
shows the joke still when you can't
remember the [ __ ] references it just
it absolutely kills it Costco they went
to Costco he bought up one of those big
[ __ ] gallons of [ __ ] just it on a
dairy chugged it anyway so they did
something on El Chapo El Chapo they said
I can't remember like just [ __ ]
killed this person's whole family took
that kid and something I don't believe
it like took his kids and then flew them
to Colombia and then threw him off a
bridge it's like really that there's not
any bridges in Mexico you never know
what to believe but I got to tell you
when you go south of the US you do not
want to piss anybody off as far as I can
tell that's some next-level [ __ ] and I
can say that because I just read papers
from the United States okay they that's
just that's just next-level like you
know you mad at somebody and then you
know how you get your revenge is just
some extra that out killing Pablo one
time I had to put the book down like
three times some of the [ __ ] they just
said that the guy didn't I don't know if
the [ __ ] guy did this [ __ ] but I'm at
one time hearing that the guy at a party
night and everybody's out there by the
pool standing around you know and
what's-his-face there
Pablo Escobar's standing there you know
everybody's ignoring the weight that
he's putting on as he sits there in his
[ __ ] Haggar actions flex you know seem
to like those he stretched and you know
still tucked him in right at the waist
you know I may talk to him riding the
waist didn't push the pants down didn't
do the [ __ ] shirt untucked he tucked
it right in and they said that he he
allegedly found one of his uh one of the
people didn't want to not as one amazed
I don't know what allegedly was stealing
so they tied this guy's legs together
and his arms behind the his back and
they threw him in the house pool and
just watched him drown if everyone was
standing there at the party you know
let's say they must have been a lot of
ice shaking and drinks after that ones
like so it's it's a Victorian huh Pablo
mr. Escobar I don't want to go in the
pool
yeah people getting their faces ripped
off is it torture and death they're like
peeling their [ __ ] faces back this is
not funny this is not what this podcast
is about why is just [ __ ] steal of
Denver game so [ __ ] boring is because
I have the sound down I just don't give
a [ __ ] the AFC's just a walking wounded
lot this burger is a [ __ ] man look at
the guys getting bumped by lime and he
stays in there like I he has like
[ __ ] he stays in the pocket like
Steve Grogan used to used to stay in the
pocket did anybody remember that any old
Pats fans out there
you [ __ ] [ __ ] their business back
when you could literally good hammer a
[ __ ] quarterback drive you a helmet
right under his chin and then lift him
off the ground and pile drive him into
the [ __ ] astroturf which is like it
and tackled in a parking lot that's been
painted green and steamed rogram he
would go back for a pass this back when
he had that [ __ ] neck brace and he
had such a long neck he could still see
like six inches of neck right even with
the neck brace and there'd be some
defensive lineman just running
full-speed right at him and he would
just hang onto it hang onto it hang onto
it and then he would throw the ball and
the camera would follow the football and
does he let it go you'd see just the
beginning of that [ __ ] lineman
drilling him and he'd go flying right
out the right side of your screen a left
side depending on which way he was going
down the field to Stanley Morgan you
know Russ Francis one of those [ __ ]
guys right Terrell Jackson who else did
we have back then I can't even [ __ ]
remember Hasselbeck it Hasselbeck whose
son was the one who said we want the
ball and we're going to score
Don ass'll back I think was just dead
all right anyways where the [ __ ] am I
yeah Roethlisberger is like that that
guy stands in the pocket takes to [ __ ]
in it and speak in which to I know as a
lot of Kansas City fans were probably
pissed off at the calls Tom Brady got
and the lack of calls that Alex Smith
got and I'm a Patriots fed you're
absolutely right but that is not Tom
Brady's fault okay and I'm hoping most
of you guys in Kansas City can hear what
I'm saying because you're not as upset
because you got to see your baseball
team win the World Series all right so
you got that going for you half of your
professional teams won championships
this year that's pretty [ __ ] good
right Tom Brady earned those calls okay
this is if you want Alex Schmidt to get
those calls in the future in the yeah he
has to make the NFL owners a lot more
money than he is and that's just a
simple fact and people called to tom
brady rules it isn't it's the superstar
rules you know Jordan gets away with the
push right ones last time you Kobe
Bryant what does Kobe Bryant have to do
to get you know well he's not helping
anymore but back in the day you could be
standing in the lane before the [ __ ]
game starts and if he runs into you that
they're going to call it on you he's
literally have to eat have to [ __ ]
tie an axe to the front of his knee and
[ __ ] jump into you and cut your head
off before you know there was a way to
call offsetting they would have it's
just it's just how it works but um I
have to say as much as he earned the
calls that one where he was getting
in fact and he switched it to his left
hand and threw it and they still gave
him the call was [ __ ] ridiculous I
even as a patriot said I was at home
going well what the [ __ ]
give me a break but you know I'll take
it of course you'll take it the same way
you would have but uh I don't care just
feeds a great team and as you know Alec
Smith I think he's going to be a really
[ __ ] great quarterback but you got to
have it all man you got have a coach and
the ownership and all that [ __ ] and
lucky enough that we have that in uh in
New England today go that's me trying to
not be a [ __ ] all right and oh god I
can't wait to go home and watch that
[ __ ] Carolina Panther game man I
think you're going to see like all these
people that they were saying on the
heir-apparent
to [ __ ] Tom Brady and Peyton Manning
I think it's uh I think it's
what's-his-face they're on the Pampas I
can't remember his [ __ ] name what is
wrong with me he went to Auburn righty
that's a Superman Tech Cam Newton there
we go
anyway so I'd better let you guys know
this I'm supposed to read this [ __ ] here
but of course don't get a type of my
[ __ ] password which takes forever for
[ __ ] sakes
I gotta have a [ __ ] 20 letter
password and numbers because God knows
everybody wants to break into my
computer and read my dick jokes here
Oh Andrew asked you guys he said please
ask the listeners to put relevant
subject lines in their emails if they
want them read putting hey doesn't help
with a thousand thousands a week trying
not to miss any of the good ones thanks
I probably could nice and that up a
little bit he sort of texts me that
really quickly yeah so if you guys have
a subject whatever you know anything you
know [ __ ] Tom Brady Tom Brady rules or
something like that you know if you just
do that instead of writing like hey dot
dot dot and then an email be like what
the [ __ ] was with those calls you know I
mean I'll bill we get it and if you want
to send an email that could possibly be
read
or who's kidding who stumbled upon by me
please send it to bill at the mm
podcast.com also if you'd like to follow
the Monday morning podcast on Twitter
it's at the mm podcast all right and
with that it's time for my attempts at
reading out loud
alright Dollar Shave Club everybody
Dollar Shave Club you know lots of
players will be sporting playoff beards
now that the post season is here leave
that to the pros all right kick off your
year the right way with a fresh blade
shave that's why millions of others have
joined dollarshaveclub.com Dollar Shave
Club knows the key to getting an amazing
shave is simple 1 use a fresh Dollar
Shave Club blade to use the doctor
copies easy shaper that's it Dollar
Shave Club delivers amazing razors right
to your door for a third of the price of
those greedy mega razor corporations
that means listeners who switch now can
afford the luxury of shaving with the
fresh blade anytime and save hundreds
this year and when you combine that
fresh blade with their doctor cavity
shaped butter it just glides
it's unimaginably smooth just imagine
the smoothest thing ever and it's
smoother than that you can't even
imagine how smooth it is I'm telling you
it's not your average safe foam it will
shape them it won't dry out your skin
the all-natural ingredients leave your
skin feeling soft smooth and moisturized
after every shave take it from me use a
fresh Dollar Shave Club blade with dr.
cavities easy shave butter if you want
the most gentle shave imaginable
dollarshaveclub.com slash bird today
join that Dollar Shave Club calm slash /
sorry I went a little light with the dr.
coffee so I'm in a hotel room right now
I don't need anybody knocking it to us
13 to 9 what's going on here the Broncos
are knocking on the door here in the red
zone what do you like oh do you like I
think the Steelers are going to win this
one I just do I think I don't know why I
just think that they're going to win
here
pushing on the white bill you barely
watched any football this year oh by the
way congratulations to the Alabama
Crimson Tide I can't believe I forgot to
uh you know give them a shout out there
[ __ ] Nick Saban five count of five
NCAA football championships I mean this
guy's like beyond a [ __ ] legend
beyond the legend unbelievable game
congratulations to Clemson for getting
there I hope you guys get back again I
was rooting for Clemson of course just
because it's fun to root against Alabama
I don't really hate those guys it's just
fun to root against them because you
know who I necessarily pilant on anybody
can just become a college football fan
and just root for the best [ __ ] team
I don't want to do that right and that
[ __ ] onside kick call [ __ ]
tremendous what a call and the way that
they hit the whole thing that was the
game right there unbelievable so anyway
there we go plowing it me undies ow
Jesus Wow geez bottom me undies me
undies drying your balls in 2016 blue to
be undies me undies grab my balls and
see what I mean they're nice and dry
take that look off your face
you like my balls no matter what the
race put on me undies and dry out your
taint and even make them for the ladies
oh yeah they'll dry out your [ __ ]
clam even if you're in the mood me
undies what's your secret to the to New
Year's resolutions make the first step
real easy like the first thing you do
every day put on underwear this year out
with the old in with the new
step into a fresh new pair of me undies
the world's most comfortable underwear
and it's the easiest resolution you can
make head to me undies comm choose from
a variety of styles and limited edition
pattern for both men in the [ __ ] way
and he'll be delivered right to you do
me undies is the next level of underwear
you thought your dick was comfortable
now where do you take lady it take you a
ball to the next level every pair is
made with their signature modal model
mil fabric proven to be twice as soft as
cotton wear where did you prove that at
the x-games like I they say that like
you can
you can do research and find that out
anyway they don't just feel better than
regular undies
they make you feel invincible what are
they underoos when you're eight years
old come on and it's guaranteed be the
most comfortable underwear you've ever
worn or your first pair is free so start
your New Year's in don't start your New
Year's out with old saggy underwear make
it change head to me undies dot-com
slash burn right now and get 20% off
your first order if you know like your
relationship and you want to take back
ground that you gave away the only way
to do it is to get brand new underwear
okay because once you're comfortable
with somebody you walk around half and
anew it anyways right and they're not
going to take you seriously if you got
holes in your underwear with pubes
sticking out like some sort of fucked-up
vegetable all right
that's disgusting anyways plus shipping
is always free for all the orders in US
and Canada so for 20 percent off your
first order of the world's most
comfortable underwear head to me undies
comm slash burger right now and lastly
but not leastly although they kept the
horse from the old Mile High Stadium I
went to a game man I told you that right
stamps com1 great resolution sorry I'm
watching TV here one great resolution
you can make for the new year
maximize every minute and every dollar
of your small business I know an easy
way to do that actually I don't stamps
comm is telling me about it think about
how much time you've wasted going to the
post office driving there finding
parking not score in any coke all right
stamps calm is a better way to get
postage just use what you already have
your computer and your printer to get
official US postage who the [ __ ] is Jim
Simpson man just died he had a great run
89 years good for him
everything you would do with the post
office you can do right from your desk
with just a fractious a fraction of the
cost of one of those expensive postage
meters I use stamps com any time I'm
selling posters I'm a [ __ ] if I can
figure it out so can you it's so
convenient I can do it right from my
home standing in my brand new [ __ ] me
on these how you like that huh right now
site is like an advertising threesome
here right now or a twosome right now
sign up for spam calm and use my last
name bar for this special offer for
weeks
applause $110 bonus offer that of course
includes postage into digital scale
don't wait go to stance calm before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
BER be URR and mercifully that's the end
of me reading out loud for this week
here's a stat I had to look up because
daugh my rarest sent me a text I try to
drop names here by the way I'm on his
podcast this past week da my rarest sent
me a text this morning he goes how many
quarterbacks have you ever seen in the
NFL have a Hail Mary pass so a
successful Hail Mary pass once in their
career
forget about twice in the same season
and I had to go look it up I was like I
got to I got to find this out man I got
to find out you know if anybody's ever
done it I guess I was like there's no
way anybody's done it in my lifetime of
watching the last 30-something years are
watching football holy [ __ ] I've been
watching football for 38 years
oh my god I'm old I started watching it
religiously in about 1978 yeah about
that 78 79 jesus [ __ ] christ
put it this way the first Super Bowl I
watched was Superbowl 12th and there are
50 so there you go wow this is going to
be my what would that be my 50/50 first
you [ __ ] idiot my 39th Super Bowl 50
minus 12 plus I watch 12 right yeah so
that thing they're young yeah there's a
lot of people right now actually think
I'm wrong but it's true it's my 39th I'm
going to be watching anyways let's plow
ahead here so I looked it up
successful Hail Marys okay there's only
one guy that I saw since they started
keeping this fat in 1975 at least on
Wikipedia I didn't go to the football
reference calm which I love the one guy
who's ever done done
wife since they kept the stats in 1975
Steve Bartkowski Steve Bartowski and
there's no way to picture Steve
Bartowski and not have the song this
song go through your head I never
thought I could be so free throw on the
ball too many white shoes Johnson and to
another guy he looked like the Greatest
American Hero he did in 1978 against the
Saints and then he did it again in 1983
against the 49ers in the NFC West which
back then was only four teams
it was the Los Angeles Rams the New
Orleans Saints the Atlanta Falcons and
the San Francisco 49ers the quarterbacks
of Steve Bartkowski 7080 Bartkowski
Archie Manning and I think they had a
quarterback controversy Pat Haden Vince
Ferragamo back and forth for Vince
confer gamma tried to take the money and
went to the [ __ ] CFL Jewish never saw
him again
and it would be Steve the burger Jim
Plunkett in 78 I did this was [ __ ]
joke bartnik one time we tried to name
all the starting quarterbacks in the NFL
in 1978 we went around the league I so I
think it was AFC East was Bert Jones Bob
Griese Steve Grogan Richard Todd and Joe
Ferguson for the bills but it was Terry
Bradshaw Dan Pastorini who the [ __ ] was
quarterback for the Browns it was either
Mike Phipps or Brian sight and then the
Bengals was Kenny Anderson Kenny the
candle and columns were sent they call
him Kenny the candle because one blow
and he was out you ever see that one on
NFL Films when they cut the Kenny
Anderson he's like I'll [ __ ]
Collinsworth
and let's use Craig Morton I'll just do
the AFC because I know it was [ __ ]
driving everybody nuts but this is what
I have to do it now because now it's in
my head
Craig Morton was with the Orange Crush
Broncos Ken Stabler
Kenny snake Stabler for the the rate is
Dan Fouts the great Dan Fouts air
Coryell with its yajuz Jim Zorn with
Seattle and then I [ __ ] there's always
one that gets me who the [ __ ] is with
the chief was before Blackledge was
after Len Dawson who the [ __ ] was the
quarterback there that good one for you
this some poor bastard in Kansas City
right now screaming it who the [ __ ] was
it I even know I think like the
Buccaneers had Gary Huff Lynn Dickey was
out in Green Bay Jim Hart was it how the
[ __ ] do I remember those I remember
Kansas City Kansas City I can look this
up Kansas City chief quarterback hey
it's going to get better guys I played
drums this week out and I played with
the Colin Hay from that at work alright
I'm going to tell a story in a second it
just [ __ ] deal with this here Kansas
City Chiefs QB 1978 why do I care why do
I [ __ ] care list of Kansas City chief
quarterbacks this was [ __ ] made for me
well who's the last person who [ __ ]
went to this starting quarterback season
this season
geez they've had some guys around Joe
Montana Warren Moon Rich Gannon alright
here we go here we go back at it out
backing it up 1970 I I'd never get this
Mike Livingston and Tony Adams this is
the one that always [ __ ] gets me Lenny
Dawson left in 1975 and then Mike
Livingston took over
you know there was a guy who played for
the Bengals that Bill Walsh was talking
about he only played for one season he
got [ __ ] injured and Bill Walsh to
this day still said he's the greatest
quarterback that he ever coached but
he's probably still trying to motivate
or he was anyways passed away probably
still trying to motivate [ __ ] Montana
or a young even after they retired get
him to rake the leaves better that day
of some [ __ ] I can't remember the guys
[ __ ] me but that's one to look up uh
anyways so yeah this this week I did a
Greg Behrendt show at Largo and those
things too it's not quite like the
goddamn Comedy Jam this was one where
they actually have people for the most
part it's musicians coming out and
telling funny stories and this is
something that Greg did a number of
years ago and he's brought the show back
and so anyways I mean let me get the
lineup here so don't [ __ ] this up I did
take a picture of it I'm so [ __ ]
disorganized I apologize alright so it
was calling hey Tom Morello
myself and Chris Fairbanks another
comedian so those two comedians and then
two magicians and I got to uh I got to
play with the band told some stories and
I got to play with the band and then
afterwards I got to play with Collin hey
and we played a who can it be now which
was uh just beyond a [ __ ] throw he
was the nicest [ __ ] guy so generous
to let me play and he had this really
cool way that he wanted to bring me out
he goes uh he just went out there he's
telling stories he's [ __ ] hilarious
and then he just randomly goes you know
and I had the weirdest dream last night
I was dreaming I was you know playing a
show and I was playing you know who can
it be now in the crowd collapsed because
it's such a huge hit and he goes the
weirdest thing yeah bill burr was on
drums like you know and I just waited a
second then I just walked out and sat
down everybody started laughing and then
he told this great story I'm not gonna
repeat the story just because I
it's his story so I'm sure if he wants
to tell it on the podcast he can but he
tells his [ __ ] hilarious story that
ends with the word [ __ ] and he told me
after I say [ __ ] basically you do the
drum fill intro and then we'll go into
the song and there he played it and I
went off when I'm pretty good man and
actually uh [ __ ] unreal man I played
like 20 years by myself in a rehearsal
space until it's finally dawned on me
that I'm supposed to be out interacting
with other [ __ ] people so now uh and
I've kind of opened Pandora's box I just
I told you I made this rule that I'm not
going to ask to sit in but if somebody
asked me to play I'm going to [ __ ]
play all right
that includes if I come to your town and
if I'm drinking at a bar if I go out to
a bar and your local band is played if
you come up to me and ask me to sit in
with your band I'm going to [ __ ] do
it
all right I don't and this is a warning
it's a warning I'm going to do it and
I'm going to [ __ ] up so you know you
want a story I'll [ __ ] do it because
it's fun as hell to me and it's weird I
don't feel any pressure whatsoever
because I'm a comedian
what's the pressure you can sit down and
play drums he's going to stink of course
he is everybody already knows it so it's
fine plus everybody just looks at the
singer anyways but it's a it's a lot of
fun and I've been getting psycho back
into lesson and I told you I've been
taken I've been taking some lessons you
remember a long time ago when I watched
that Mars Volta video and I was talking
about their drummer who's Davy which at
the time I was go holy [ __ ] look at this
guys [ __ ] unbelievable blah blah blah
well from doing that he must have heard
the clip he reached out to me on Twitter
and lo and behold he lives in LA and
every once in a while I go by and I take
a lesson with the guy and he's a [ __ ]
unbelievable teacher and he's been
teaching me techniques so might you know
I'm one of those guys I grabbed the
drumsticks the same way like a toddler
would would just might fit me
[ __ ] fists just right over both of
them and it was causing my arms to be
doing all the work at my forum if faint
drummers are listening to this if you
have like that [ __ ] you know that
pain in your forearms and all that you
know that I was kind of going through
that [ __ ] and he is teaching me this
technique where you let the stick do the
work and it's holding it in this
particular way that does not seem
[ __ ] natural at all and it has been a
[ __ ] but you know incrementally
I've been gradually working its way into
my playing and it's been it's totally
been worth it and we've been going
through this jazz book and like most
students like I work on something for
three seconds and then want to go on to
the next thing so I can have that sense
of accomplishment and just get through a
whole [ __ ] page and and I was moving
ahead and every time I'd go to the
lesson I would still not have the first
thing down and I've been taking lessons
you know on and off sensitive summer I
mean I get busy and I can't go for like
a month or something but I'm still on
that first page and it finally dawned on
me in the past week to be like dude just
work on this one [ __ ] thing and [ __ ]
everything else I just sort of sat down
15 minutes a day just working on this
thing you know make it a little bit of
an improvement and then being [ __ ] I'm
going to start over blah blah blah and
all that [ __ ] and I actually had a great
lesson this week where I think he
actually was saying that I was just I
was finally starting to improve which
made my [ __ ] weak so anyways I have
another [ __ ] go into some rambling
all over the place what are we up to
here 45 minutes Jesus Christ oh can we
[ __ ] get on with this here oh by the
way somebody told me to watch the show
top boy t.o.p boy on Netflix and I want
our Netflix to life like I can figure
out how to search when I'm on the
Internet I can't [ __ ] do it when I'm
on the TV I don't how do you search when
you're on the TV if anybody knows I
would really appreciate it but anyways
I'm going to be
I'm going to be playing out again this
week I'm doing that Bonzo bash thing I'm
hosting the Bonzo bash co-hosting and I
don't know who I'm co-hosting with it's
going to be an Anaheim this Friday night
and Bryant Ishii's
wonderful event or all these drummers
that I grew up watching sit down and
play Led Zeppelin songs which is going
to be this [ __ ] I'm going to get to host
it and with somebody else it's going to
be [ __ ] awesome so and I will be
sitting in for one song once again
risking total humiliation but you know
I'll probably get add to my stuff who
gives a [ __ ] right
but anyways oh I know what I wanted to
talk about [ __ ] the Arizona Cardinals
Packers game I started to talk about it
and you know you would think last week
after watching that dude on the Bengals
intercept the ball and then [ __ ] walk
into the locker room like well I guess
that's that right you think that these
these damn kids today they'd learned
something Patrick Peterson who I [ __ ]
love LSU kid right incomplete fourth
down that ought to [ __ ] do it two and
a half minutes left this guy's walking
down the sideline waving to the crowd
doing any dandiya blowing kisses to the
crowd like it's over when he's playing
the package and Aaron [ __ ] righteous
[ __ ] hilarious two and a half minutes
of football left and he's walking around
doing that and what happened two minutes
and twenty five football seconds later
he gets beat on a jump ball in the
[ __ ] endzone on a Hail Mary to send
it into overtime [ __ ] unbelievable
how many times did somebody kind of
[ __ ] do that how many times he going
to run down the field you got the
football you not pass the goal line you
already start holding it out and dawn
baby slaps it out of your hand oh you
[ __ ] you know you spiked it over you
know over your back you know that one we
could throw it down over your shoulder
and you'd get big toes across the end
zone but the ball is and how many
[ __ ] times you're going to see people
do that I just don't understand why I
don't get it so anyways let's plow ahead
here all right here's some of the
questions or the letters for this week
all right pasta bill if you want to get
good at making pasta of course I do
begin with Gennaro Contaldo videos on
foodtube all right I don't know if I
said I'm probably the favorite GE n a
are ro and then the last name is cont al
do s no do apostrophe s can call those
the guy taught me so much I even wish
them a happy birthday also pay attention
to sorts of flour you're using cheers to
you and your Mondays yeah what's going
some people use flour some people use
that semolina some people use a mixture
of both I tie I like doing I think it
goes back to when I was a kid I was
almost kids like playing in mud puddles
you know what I mean so it was uh
there's just something about that I
think that's why like I like making like
like pie crusts and [ __ ] like that it's
just a big gooey [ __ ] mess fun but
I'll definitely I'll check that out if I
can get online here
alright cooking Asian food alright bill
how are you you freckled [ __ ] Jesus
Jesus no Happy New Year huge fan from
Belgium here nice bedlam in Belgium ACDC
flick of the switch album how many
[ __ ] balls are you going to drop on
painting here this could be his last
game ever what are you doing Jesus quite
when his shoulder pads get so small let
me see show the pads on people in the
[ __ ] the shoulder pads was so big the
shirt didn't even cover your belly
you should run around with half shirts
on by the way to grunt pull his pants up
or get a longer [ __ ] Jersey he's
starting to look like a waitress at
Hooters
alright a huge fan from Belgium here I'm
Shane he showed his mid-drift
probably the run run breath or to nose
you know the little ass country that
people know about because of Austin
Powers I thought I know them from I
thought isn't that's not Brussels the
muscles from Brussels that was the guy
whose guys do the splits
now [ __ ] is a guy's name
he wasn't I must break you
he wasn't Steven Seagal was the other
guy from blood swab gives a [ __ ] Belgium
yeah Luxembourg and Belgium right right
there tucked in there right there Battle
of the Bulge right there and in France
and not Germany my nut between Amsterdam
in the [ __ ] Denmark their Copenhagen
tucked right there staring at the
[ __ ] bad teeth of the dirty English
aren't you looking across the channel
maybe you're not maybe if I had a map at
finding you know
all right loved after afters for family
please come to our our freckle of a
country
dude I'm definitely going to go there
that's are going to go there without
[ __ ] doubt I'm uh we're waiting to
hear about the second season for efforts
of family the pitch went [ __ ] great
went out of there we were all excited I
got a great feeling about it and I'm
going to let you guys know as soon as I
find out like but I got a good feeling
about so and I'm definitely going to do
a European tour I did Australian Asia
last year so this time it's time to head
the other way I'm going to do Europe
this time and I want to hit all the
countries I've been to
I'd like to add a few more and I also
want to do a little bit of Eastern
Europe but if we do get a second season
I don't know how many episodes that
would be I think it'd be at least ten
and then you know we got to sit down and
write them and we want to make it as
good as the first season you know and
even better which of course we do it's
going to take a lot of time so I got to
kind of figure out you know once they
give us the yea or nay on that but like
I said I got a really really really
positive vibe a lot of laughs in the
room and which is always good so anyways
he said the guy says anyway I've heard
you talking about cooking more Asian
food
oh wait this is different
oh it's just saying that sorry penny
this is the same guy from Belgium
because anyways I've heard you talking
about wanting to cook more Asian food on
your podcast since I love cooking as
well please allow me to recommend you
some Korean cuisine has a lot of spicy
food
oh yeah kimchi and all that stuff yeah
I've been to those Korean barbecue and
all the stuff I love all of that stuff
but two bits just so different from the
stuff here I'm really intimidated about
cooking it which is so stupid you know I
thought what I'm afraid of it I should
just just sit down and be like okay
let's start with something easy how do
you make the sticky rice you know if you
could just make sticky rice alone that's
the [ __ ] right that's the best [ __ ]
rice there is now in everybody tell me
it's not [ __ ] healthy I don't give a
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] delicious Korean
cuisine has a lot of spicy food which is
great for losing weight since you tend
to be full more quickly and drink more
water plus a lot of other health
benefits if you are interested please
check out again it's M aan gch I on
YouTube oh I got to do this
I gotta guess I go I guess this is a
lady she's a Korean housewife who is
funny as hell and learns teaches you you
said learns you how to cook it teaches
teaches you how to cook great
traditional and overall easy recipes now
you got to teach me some Belgian words I
gave you one their recommendations are
uh Belgian words Belgian iam
recommendations are spicy pork stir-fry
jinxing chicken I don't know I says it's
J AJ AME Ong Jo Jo Myung that sounds
like an annoying character in [ __ ]
Star Wars which is black bean sauce
noodles some other [ __ ] that I can't say
Korean barbecue which I bet you've had
before yeah
what is that the hacky American thing
like that Korean food I went to a Korean
barbeque I literally just said that
Japanese cuisine is mostly salty sweet
and umami
what does umami mean is that Oh mommy
burger
better that flavors lots of vegetables
no butter soy sauce which is amazing for
you and rich enriched taste yeah I got
to tell you mad people when I went over
to a German they will [ __ ] it in shape
people are just in shape over there you
know I bet if you have fat in Asia they
just mean look at that rich [ __ ]
he must be traveling he's got enough
money to get to an Appleby doctor
[ __ ] a I'm too tired I didn't want to
say Applebees Applebees not a fattening
place is it let's pick this up Jesus
don't just wrap up the podcast okay if
I'm going to be this off right now what
the [ __ ] is going to happen when I go to
do my shows tonight all right now
Chinese food I don't know a lot about
cool to know is that Chinese food in the
States in Europe is not actual Chinese
food
no it isn't that's the surreptitious way
of trying to [ __ ] kill it that's what
they're trying to do they know we have
the bomb right China is attacking us on
two levels right now giving us food
that's going to give us a heart attack
and they're going to [ __ ] with our
economy somehow somehow we're tied in
with them and they're going to pull the
[ __ ] rug out anyways you said it's
modified for our taste buds but I'm
guessing they have amazing stuff too
yeah we think I would think so um no
[ __ ] if I get the hiccups here Thai and
Vietnamese food it's mostly spring rolls
Jesus Christ you going going through the
whole continent here let me get some
water
[ __ ] completely mr. glass look at
that angle here
lastly okay no tide Vita means mostly
spring rolls spicy curry I love our guy
from [ __ ] Belgium is telling me about
Asian food are you at least Asian lots
of coriander which I personally detest
because it tasted AB dishwater product
dishwasher product lastly if you really
want to go hardcore try out North Korean
food
it's basically starving yourself you'll
be able to see your ginger pube dingdong
without a mirror again in no time pretty
edgy huh yes you're making fun of the
fact that they're under a dictator that
doesn't feed him very edgy very edgy I
hope this help - go [ __ ] yourself
lots of love Fournier and Oh Cleo do oh
[ __ ] I guess I'll give that you know I
love how Asia stops with people that we
can you know it doesn't go into India
that's also Asian right is in the Middle
East isn't that also Asia Russia you
know anyways like that guy named [ __ ]
Forrest Gump alright hey Billy Beane
been a fan of the podcast for a while
now yada yada I need some advice or just
a fresh perspective on what to do I'm 23
yeah the primary life dropped out of
high school like a [ __ ] at 17 got my
GED when I was 19 I you back in the game
you back in the game and is excited to
start becoming a productive member of
society everything was going good
paycheck meant the dating pool opened up
tried a few jobs etc but now I'm 23 I
quit my job to go to to go to school for
advertising slash art at an artsy
College should probably mention the only
thing I'm truly good at is art mainly
pen and ink stuff
what dude that's a great thing and you
can make a ton of [ __ ] money doing
that
it's just that schools generally
speaking are not geared towards that so
yeah you were [ __ ] bored and then you
took [ __ ] that you weren't good at made
you feel like an [ __ ] you [ __ ]
drop out you party for a few years right
bagged a couple of who is and now you're
coming back dude you find you're 23 dude
you're fine that was eight months ago I
missed the sign I missed the sign update
it just lacked the general knowledge
slash support ongoing about it I spent
six months grinding the living [ __ ] out
of drawing trying to achieve something I
might be able to take some pride in
didn't work I was just going to say
you're being too hard on yourself your
next line is I'm hard on myself to the
point where I'm thinking I'll never be
handed
metal is the greatest that ever [ __ ]
lived so why bother Jesus dude
well listen Richard Pryor's the greatest
of all time and I'll never come close to
that guy that that's not going to stop
me you just try to see how close you can
come some people you can't pass and
that's alright you know you just try to
come as close to try to just like try to
go as high up the all-time ladder as you
possibly can and who knows if you keep
pushing yourself this is you you don't
know what your limits are until you keep
[ __ ] throwing yourself out there
especially if you're hard on yourself
you probably be in way you're way better
than you think you are you're going to
be fine all right you're depressing me
here anyways I've since quit drawing and
now do nothing but troll around dating
sites all day and hooking up with
semi-decent looking women women as a way
to stay positive and cure boredom I'm
not lazy I've done primarily manual
labor jobs and though I have the back
for it but Jesus Christ I can't force
myself to pull the trigger on anything
because I can't be the top of the crop
or the very goddamn best I won't be
fulfilled I've been standing at a
crossroads my dick in my hand for nearly
a year any sort of advice be [ __ ]
amazing don't hold back if you think I
need to be ripped a new one I can handle
it thanks go [ __ ] yourself yeah dude
you've got yourself into a completely
paralyzed state here but it's like you
got it you just bought a guitar and
because you're not Jimi Hendrix within
the first two weeks you're going to
[ __ ] quit all right if Jimi Hendrix
did that he wouldn't be Jimi Hendrix all
right all right look just if you
whatever you like to do in life just go
out and do it all right and enjoy it and
don't put that level of pressure on
yourself like what would you is your dad
like the Great Santini is something I'm
trying to figure out why you like this
but like the reason why you can't pull
the trigger on anything else in life is
because you actually have a strong I
think you have a strong sense on what
makes you happy in what you want to do
all right and you know that despite the
fact that you're being totally negative
of what you're drawing you know that
that's what you want to do and you have
such a passion for it that you're that
hard on yourself and then also it's
preventing you from getting a job at the
[ __ ] Costco or wherever the goddamn
place you're going to end up [ __ ]
working at I would I don't know if I was
you I would continue drawing I get into
computers and all that there's all kinds
of stuff I think people do drugs on
computers and they turn that into
building websites which helps to pay for
that their studio and the [ __ ] that they
really want to do there's been tons of
money to make in the arts don't don't
let anybody ever [ __ ] tell you that
there isn't did you just helping people
make it in show business
alright the people get headshots give
acting classes and all that just doing
that [ __ ] people make a small [ __ ]
fortune so if you're actually a talented
artist you can actually you're going to
be fine you just have to stop beating
the [ __ ] out of yourself alright so just
pay attention to that voice and you have
motels you can't do something just tell
it to shut the [ __ ] up basically even if
you have to say it out love you don't
just make sure you're not looking at
somebody you care about as they're
telling your story when you think of
those thoughts just you know maybe maybe
Satan your brain first alright
okay advice no one to relate to Jesus
he's a [ __ ] gloomy this week alright
advice no one to relate to causing
loaning loneliness alright hey Billy
bats love the podcast you stand up
efforts a family they all put a smile on
my face well that's great okay
I'm sensing that all the sudden now the
smile is going to go away I hope you
read this because the other that my
problem is I have no one to relate to
and I fear I might as well read this
here I hope you read this because I've
been doing everything positive but I
just can't seem to get my life where I
want it to be it's a bit of a long road
so please bear with me I'll [ __ ] it it's
a long email did you know I can't read
out loud alright my problem is I have no
one to relate to and I fear I might be
cut this might be causing me
to be lonely in life I fear that if I
continue the way I'm going I may never
get over I'm in my last semester of
college in an engineering program and it
made almost no friends throughout my
entire stay at college I am at the top
of my classes and I'm lining up jobs at
big tech companies now you're probably
imagining some point Dexter with the
pocket or pocket protector and all that
actually I was but exactly that was the
picture you were painting sir quite the
opposite actually I've been working out
for a few years now and I have one and I
am one of the jacked people in my
classes all right so now on picture is
that dude in American Psycho highly
achieving totally shredded cannot relate
to human beings I dress well eat healthy
please tell me you don't listen to Huey
Lewis in the news and always make sure
to keep myself clean I feel like I might
alienate my classmates from interacting
with me they probably think I'm just a
jock in their class where it's quite the
opposite I'm into gaming chests and all
of that dude would you like a [ __ ]
Renaissance man here so I figure I might
try to interact with the opposite crowd
the non geeky people I know a way to
meet people is to get out there and do
something I I like doing playing some
sport or joining a club or volunteering
the problem is with my program of my
work I have little time to be doing much
else the only free time I have is Friday
or Saturday nights that I spend by
myself playing video games or playing
guitar because I have nothing else to do
well you could go out those night all
right it wasn't always this way
it was like a movie when I was in high
school my life was completely the
opposite I didn't work out eat healthy
work hard or nothing but I always found
ways to make new friends make people
laugh and start conversations now that
I'm doing everything right it seems my
only problem is socially I'll Jesus
Christ dude so you know what you're
doing you're just too busy I fear once I
graduate college things will only get
worse I lost all of my fame my family
apart my older brother who is in another
country so once I graduate college I'll
truly be alone no one to grab a beer
with no one to help me move or anything
help me move or anything despite all
this I try to be positive and thanks for
what I have
and what I have accomplished sorry for
the long email and go [ __ ] yourself yeah
dude you just look you already know how
to make friends I would you need to make
time to do it playing video games by
yourself is very antisocial playing
guitar is always cool that's fun why
don't you play guitar with somebody else
find somebody plays drums to play bass
get together do some covers you know Jam
[ __ ] around you know drink some beers
invite some ladies over you get every
week you just add some more [ __ ] right
you know start taking bets open your own
[ __ ] and not draftkings you know maybe
start selling coke just keep expanding
your ring of social interaction
I'm obviously [ __ ] with you but no I
would uh there's a bunch of people that
are into video games let you find
somebody that you can play against can
you do that anymore the kids do that or
you have to go online to do it you know
is that like corny now the two people
not sitting next to each other with an
Atari with the joystick and the one red
button is we passed that I don't [ __ ]
know but it seems like you know how to
do that stuff he just got busy and with
all your achievement you you know
sometimes you know when you go after a
goal some things suffer alright
I've talked about this numerous times
when I was on you know when I was 36
years old I was I was [ __ ] living
alone in a studio apartment that they
call the one-bedroom sleeping on a futon
I remember days just going by going what
the [ __ ] have I done the only thing I've
worked on is trying to become a comedian
everything else was at the starting line
and over the next 10 years I just worked
on some [ __ ] like that
so that's all you need to do alright
Jesus Christ I'm starting to feel like
dr. Phil here all right what do we got
here third and goal Broncos have the
ball with three minutes left I'm doing a
[ __ ] podcast touchdown Broncos
alright alright Broncos now you go
celebrate and act like a bunch of
[ __ ] idiots when Ben Roethlisberger
has three minutes left this one is not
over alright so what does this do this
puts them up by five
people in the crowd holding up two
fingers like the crowds going to look at
them oh yeah yeah we should go for two
shouldn't we we shouldn't just be up by
six thank you thank you view in the
[ __ ] mezzanine level ah [ __ ] but we
have to go to Denver is this going to be
one more one more
raise it either way this is going to be
great either you get to see Brady versa
Peyton Manning one more time I'm
assuming he's retiring which is stupid
or you get to see another Patriots uh
steelers matchup we [ __ ] Big Ben Big
Ben not afraid of anything Big Ben both
great teams all right that's the podcast
for this week I apologize that my head
was kind of all over the place I don't
know what flying and going to the
[ __ ] Airport does to me
but it makes me even more [ __ ]
scatterbrain so anyways go [ __ ]
yourselves and I will talk to you on
Thursday okay all right